- Hi, I'm Nick Kroll.
- And I'm John Mulaney.
We're here at Buzzfeed.
- Yeah.
(both laughing)
We're having trouble
with this introduction
because we don't exactly know
how to describe the fact
that we're gonna be talking
to teens and tweens about sex.
- Tweens is a term I
haven't heard in a while.
(Nick laughing)
(rollicking music)
- Hi.
- Hi, Brooke.
- Hi, Brooke, how are ya'?
- This is our friend, Brooke.
- We've just met, but
we're very close friends.
- How old are you, Savanna?
- I'm 11.
- You're 11, what grade are you in?
- I'm in sixth grade.
- Sixth grade.
- You just started
sixth grade?
- Yes.
- Christopher, are you aware
that if they make another Mulaney show
that you could play young John Mulaney?
How do you feel about that?
- I don't feel like I could.
- You don't think you could capture it?
- I don't have your eyes.
- Oh, yeah.
(Nick and John laughing)
- So, um, I had a question.
What is a tampon?
- Um...
- I can handle this.
- Go ahead.
- A tampon is a name that I call John.
- It's only behind my back.
- Yeah, it's behind his back
and to his face, I call him a pad.
(John and Christopher laughing)
A tampon is a, it's a object
used by women to soak
up their menstrual blood
that they're passing through their body,
which is their period.
There's tampons, there's also pads.
I use a Diva cup.
- How do get someone to wanna ask you out?
- (Nick) Ahhh...
- Oh, that I don't know.
(Nick and John laughing)
I don't know that.
- Honestly, Brooke, this is a question,
it doesn't stop in middle school.
I think people like confidence.
- They do like confidence.
- I think, but--
- You don't have to be
comfortable with who you are, though,
you can fake it.
(Nick laughing)
Truly, like you should be ideally,
Nick is right, but I would say
- Yeah,
- You can also pretend to be
- Yes.
- Until deep into your 30s.
- Why do boys smell so bad?
(Nick laughing)
- Okay, this is a great question.
They don't know they smell
because it's been like,
have you ever heard
of the example of when you
put a frog in a pot of water,
if you slowly increase, look at me,
if you slowly increase
the water, the heat,
the frog won't know it's boiling.
- Savanna, how was your day today?
A man told me to boil a frog.
(Samantha and John laughing)
- What is the point of facial hair?
- Are you asking what our opinion is
or do we actually know about evolution,
'cause I don't know anything about it.
- I have opinions on evolution
and that it's not real.
- Yeah, I mean, why do our nails grow?
I think we're wolves and
no one wants to admit it.
Have you seen Teen Wolf?
- No.
- That's a okay movie, but
it makes an excellent point
which is when you get to high school,
you turn into a wolf.
- John, we can't spread to kids that
they're gonna turn into wolves.
- What is third base anyways?
- Well, it's a 90s hip-hop band,
a white guy who became Everlast.
That's the answer I'm
comfortable on camera giving you.
- In a baseball situation,
it's right before
you get to home base unless you get,
unless the batter strikes out
or you don't steal the base.
- John is auditioning,
currently, to play at a parent
'cause I'm uncomfortable.
- I'm doing
Field of Dreams Two.
- Why do you get hair on your butt?
- [John] On your butt?
(laughing)
- I think I get hair on my butt because
I am, I did a 23 and Me, and it turns out
that I'm 17% chiapet, and so I have hair
growing out of all parts of my body.
- If you follow the directions.
(laughing)
- Oh, yeah, what is French kissing?
- It's when you kiss with your tongue.
- Oh, I thought it was when
you kiss with cigarette breath.
The first time I French kissed a girl,
it was a truth-or-dare
and I jammed my tongue down her throat
and she did not like it.
And that girl became my wife, John.
- I didn't not like it.
(laughing)
- But you didn't like it.
- I didn't like it.
- He didn't like it.
- And he coulda done without
the hummus right before it.
(laughing)
- Why are boys so awkward?
I think boys are awkward because
probably around now, like all of a sudden,
I think boys realize that girls are like,
pretty and they might like them
and so they don't know
how to deal with that
and so they will text and
then just stop texting
for some reason, and it's like
why didn't you keep texting me?
- When do you stop getting pimples?
- Oof.
- An excellent question.
Do you know?
- There's a world where
you start getting them
in your late 30s.
I heard that if you put toothpaste on it--
- It doesn't work.
- It doesn't?
- Nope, it doesn't dry it out.
- I heard Neosporin, too.
- No.
- Well, like, so what I do before bed is--
- He has a whole regimen.
- Yeah, do you know
what a French butter is?
Like a nice, rich French butter?
I'll just take a handful of that
and I'll kind of moisturize before bed
and then wake up and
then go straight to work,
don't shower, and I have found that that
has been problematic for my skin.
But I gotta say this, golden retrievers
have never liked me more.
(laughing)
Thank you so much for watching.
Thanks for doing it, John.
- Thanks for doing it, Nick.
It was great to hear these questions
from young people that
have a lot on their minds.
- And we, I think, gave them
something more to think about.
The narrative that boys are just stupid,
I'm now like we can't do that anymore.
- I don't think they're stupid,
I think they're bad.
(upbeat happy music)
(wind whooshing)
(hinges squeaking)